I refer to this again okay so I hope
you've got your graphs still there
that's probably better than the exercise
I just gave you had to do with loss in
speed mainly I didn't address
displacement as well but we're mainly
its motion right so it's about how
things move which is why they asked all
these questions
so what a person question to you which
is for our up bender in right what's the
average velocity over the first ten
seconds okay now just before we don't
deal with that question I just want you
to be cautious and you might have
noticed as you start to enter and these
questions right but when they say say
the first ten seconds or the third
second or the fourth second you've gotta
be very cautious check is for example
what you are wouldn't you have a number
line just for time so when time is equal
to zero that's sort of we don't usually
talk about put positions in time okay
like the Fed how you were doing this or
no sir
what does it mean when you say the first
second it's the entirety of T equals
zero to T was one that's what we would
call the first second okay so if we said
the fourth second right the fourth
second begins one two three four the
four second begins fatigue was three
that's a bit confusing say that there
this is the fourth second this is the
first
oh yeah - for Tekken is uh T equals
three all the way up until T equals four
okay I know I always I often made this
error that you think the four seconds
that's what T equals four
because you're like four but actually it
started you know yeah okay all right now
therefore what is what's the let's see
what is the average velocity over the
first ten seconds can we work it out
this is where the object is at the tenth
of second okay so how are we go that
working on average velocity what do we
need what information do we do good we
need to know how far it's been displaced
okay because velocity is equal to
displacement over time okay and we
already know what the time is
so let's work it out just quickly so we
have some actual numbers here okay on T
is equal to ten to get the displacement
I'm gonna pop it back into my
displacement equation okay so here when
T is equal to ten that's ten 14 minus 10
is 4 so this is going to be 40 so that's
going to be 120 on 49 sorry that's okay
you're happy with that whatever whatever
that's all that ends up being okay so
that's where I am okay so therefore what
what do I do with that
that's my displacement R divided by time
okay so that gives you the average
velocity being 12 and 49 meters per
Dessie Dickie whatever sorry
second yes oh sorry
right thank you
all right so they go there's an average
okay I just wanna pause and have a think
about what it is geometric we've
actually worked out displacement over
time okay
displacement is our vertical axis right
that's why I've got the exporter and
times my horizontal axis so what I've
really done is I've worked out rise over
run okay and I over a certain interval
okay
so average velocity this is the key idea
it requires two points in space fun
saying that is just a fancy way of
saying I know where it is and I know
what it is
okay space it requires two points so
that's why when you take those two
points and you join them up together in
a line that's make this straight what
you get is this interval and your actual
velocity is equivalents Ukrainian right
okay sir well which would men average
velocity or average speed it's like
joining them on okay it's getting a
straight line okay but here's where it
starts to get fun because you guys know
far more than how old would you have to
be to work this out like he's 78 maybe
quite a junky array I suppose you guys
know much water quarterly you know in
calculus right so you can do much better
than an average okay gradient over two
points okay that's that's sort of
approximate okay but you can get it at
any particular point in time
okay you can get instantaneous velocity
or speed how do you get it by our old
friend okay so before when we first
introduced by calculus and stuff at
differentiating first principles we said
that you differentiate you get the
gradient function okay well if you
differentiate the displacement function
you'll get not we don't call it gradient
anymore we call it velocity okay so you
differentiate displacement and that'll
give you a velocity function okay so
that comes with with all this unbundled
sort of symbols in terminology so let me
try and explain what all these are